100 thieves the only eSports
organization cool enough to be co-signed
by Drake announced on Thursday that they
will not be buying a slot in the
franchise called duty league that's
right nadeshot the face of God he'll
have nothing to do with the games latest
attempt at bolstering their eSports
scene and if I'm being honest with you
nadeshot not being a part of this thing
like kill the [ __ ] collagen
[Music]
all right so what do I mean when I say
franchise Li we kind of throw that word
around all the time in eSports but it's
important to be clear about what that
means well what I'm talking about is an
investment from these organizations that
is long term by putting down your money
that means that you think that this
league is going to be successful over
the long term
there's no relegation players get signed
to real contracts these organizations
are then incentivized to go out and get
sponsorships and bring in revenue you
know everything you've seen from the
traditional sports model that's what we
mean when we talk franchise leagues
obviously we've all watched as League of
Legends in the overwatch league have
treaded these unknown franchising waters
over the past few years everyone's
fighting to legitimize what it means to
have a real eSports league and mimic
that traditional sports model and so
that exact same thing
that's what Call of Duty strategy
notably another game under the
Activision Blizzard sort of banner that
also houses overwatch so all these
things sound great you know players
getting paid organizations getting
opportunities to make money but why
wouldn't a hundred thieves want to be
involved
after watching nadeshot statement and
paying attention to the LCS and the
overwatch League over the last few years
it's become a little unclear to me
exactly what these organizations are
getting from what franchising means of
course for a team like 100 thieves it
makes sense for them to want to be
involved in eSports nadeshot is an
old-school eSports player and although
they do all the entertainment and
apparel stuff it makes sense that you
would want a gaming team under a gaming
org but when we talk franchising we're
talking massive amounts of money these
CDL slots are reportedly worth up to
twenty five million dollars that's the
same amount of money that a hundred
thieves raised in their entire series a
funding round so if you're an
organization that friends yourself under
apparel and entertainment and you have
all these different teams and leagues
can you really afford to spend twenty
five million dollars on an spot in a
league that is not even guaranteed to
succeed what we saw from nadeshot in
that video was obviously someone that
was heartbroken that they couldn't be
involved but I think frankly and I mean
he told us this they just couldn't
afford the fact of the matter is the CDL
is incredibly expensive it's so
expensive
and not only are there a lot of upfront
cost but there are a ton of operational
costs that we'll be spending money on
and resources on for years and we are
just not equipped and not prepared to
make that jump and to make that decision
to be all-in we just can't be the cost
is so high in fact that nadeshot went on
to say that joining the CDL could
jeopardize everything they've built that
100 days and so we have so many
different investments so much time and
so many resources that beings need to be
invested into these things that for us
to make such a costly investment in the
call of duty would possibly jeopardize
really everything that this company has
been building over the last year and a
half and two years from me so it's it's
just a risk that we can't take right now
so let me put the cost of all this in
perspective real quick 100 thieves
obviously has a lot of eggs and a lot of
baskets when they do these series a and
B funding rounds which are kind of
confusing they get a bunch of money and
then they gotta spend it on a bunch of
things now what I suggested earlier was
this slot would take up a lot of their
funding and when we're comparing a game
like cod to a game like fortnight where
players are making millions of dollars
and we have this massive World Cup with
30 million dollars on the line I just
don't think they're comparable
especially for the cost for example last
week at the cod World Championships 100
thieves is one of the best teams in the
world right now and that stream peaked
at 120,000 concurrent English viewers
that's just not comparable at all with
any of these massive game numbers like
120,000 is like a weekend stream 40 feu
in fortnight the games are not
comparable at all the fact is that 25
million-dollar price point is just not
worth the attention and revenue that 100
thieves is going to be able to generate
with this Cod spot what's more and this
goes a little bit deeper than dollars
and cents is that 100 thieves brand
really exists online and that that's
true about a lot of these eSports
organizations over the last few years
we've seen brands like 100 thieves or
faze clan sort of take over the internet
and that has nothing to do with time and
place and location and whatever city you
represent so
why would a brand like a hundred thieves
that has this stomping ground that
reaches across the entire internet want
to tie themselves to a roster slot in a
specific city in a specific game our
branding in our persona and our identity
is the lifeblood of this company and we
want to straight we want to stay true to
that and we want that to be what we
represent we're not prepared to find a
city either we're not prepared to put
our flag in one place and say this is
our home this is a worldwide brand it's
an all-encompassing brand it's something
that I want everyone to feel like
they're a part of it in more ways than
one
and picking a city and building out a
local operational team and I mean I can
talk about that for a very long time but
there are just so many different
variables that bake into City based
franchising that we just do not have the
resources to commit to it now obviously
on earth East has been down this
franchising path before with league of
legends that was kind of really where
they set their foot in eSports and
allowed to grow up that allowed the
brand to grow and start to do this
entertainment content and apparel now
what exactly did they gain from joining
the CDL they've got their franchise slot
in another game that's much more popular
and that has allowed them to sort of
gain their eSports credibility to build
off of now what is this twenty five
million dollar slot in a cod league
gonna add to the hundred thieves brand
to me it seems like the cod league
actually needs a hundred thieves way
more than they need the cod league and
if I'm being honest with you
a guy like cage shot as integral to the
call of duty seen as he is not being a
part of this thing might be the death
knell for the success of this league
there's actually more to this that would
dissuade someone like an aged shop from
wanting to get involved the fact is when
when you join a franchise League
especially an Activision Blizzard run
like we've seen with the overwatch
League you kind of have to fit a mold
you're marketed the same way as all the
other teams your uniforms look the same
and that's just not exactly a hundred
thieves buy like let's take one of their
latest signings courage and then using
the overwatch League as an example of
what the CDO will eventually look like
let's compare the two in a lot of ways
the CD
wants to be what the overwatch League is
now they're owned by the same people a
lot of those same owners are buying
teams in this league but when you break
it down could you find one player in the
overwatch League everything that the CDL
wants to be that has the same scope as a
guy like courage that 100 thieves was
able to go out and get this is a guy
that you could you know make brand deals
around they started a podcast where
which is sponsored by cash app they've
got brands like stock X or Totino's
that's what's called right fun everybody
knows who Courage's they're familiar
with this stream you know from youtube
you watched him professors love to
ariana grande in front of millions of
people and my point here is that it's
very difficult to find that kind of
scope with a team of five players within
a franchise league that are sponsored by
all the same things wear the same
jerseys and look exactly the same as
everything else it's just not a hundred
thieves at all look the reality here is
a lot of eSports organizations are young
just like a hundred thieves and it's not
clear exactly that planting your flag in
a city and joining as many franchise
leagues as possible is gonna make you a
ton of money or even match your
investment none of that is even clear
yet the idea of franchising leagues it's
safe it it makes sense on paper like a
lot of us look at it and we say yeah
that's the same as the NBA and the NFL
and we get stoked we think eSports is
gonna be exactly the same way as then
there's no formula it's not a race to
see how many franchise leagues you can
join cod is not in any way a safe bet
and I think 100 thieves treading
carefully really paves the way for a lot
of other eSports organizations to choose
their path the way they think will work
for them not necessarily rushing into
these leagues so in the wake of this
announcement Mike Rafael you might know
him as Hofstra
he made his own kind of announcement
which I found quite interesting you know
this is another OG eSports guy just like
nadeshot who came in with his take
actually in support of what 100 thieves
is doing which is particularly
interesting because his organization NV
has already announced that they are
buying into the CDO and they'll be
representing Dallas in the league you
know obviously I'm in the same boat as
the other eSports team founder is that
has to make these types of decisions and
you know for me it started actually a
long time ago when we decided to enter
into the overwatch league so when we
made that decision it was very much of a
position where when you were risking a
lot I knew personally that I was risking
a lot having to take in millions of
dollars investment capital to keep doing
what I love to do and you know we were I
think such a core called the D brand
that it's hard to let that go now of
course a lot of what Hofstra said there
is just to cod oh geez looking out for
each other he's saying that you know
nadeshot has his own organization now he
gets to choose what that means whether
he wants to do all apparel or he wants
to focus on these streamers or he's
gonna join another franchise League in
another game there's really no script to
all this and to me it's nice to see
someone who's entrenched in the sort of
traditional sports model of making
eSports work like pastro
in support of this kind of new breed of
organization like otter themes with the
voices of these two guys in mind I'm
still worried about the CEO and I'm
worried about the overwatch League too
as an eSports fan
I spend a lot more time watching 100
thieves vlog their players than I do
watching the overwatch League or the cod
worldly and I'm not necessarily saying
that that means the world's gonna fall
and the competitive eSports framework
that we have now is gonna cease to exist
it's gonna be all about celebrities and
twitch but at the end of the day I'm
glad that's someone like neisha
someone with that much scope someone
taking pictures with Drake is willing to
tread his own way and so it's refreshing
to see someone like nature a real
eSports og from back in the day who's
now wearing Rolexes and hanging out with
Drake sort of choose to do things a
little differently not necessarily copy
the way traditional Sports has worked
because that's not our world we exist on
the Internet and a chance a smart guy
he's been doing this thing for quite a
long time and him not wanting to be
involved should worry you too the fact
is we've heard a lot of rumors about
what these franchise leagues look like
we've heard rumors of
you botting with the overwatch league
which we might get into in another video
we have absolutely no idea if these
evaluations of the teams in these slots
are worth what everyone says they're
worth and my last point is about content
and I'm sure that's something you guys
are all familiar with because that's
what eSports is it's the YouTube videos
and the twitch channels that we frequent
and are addicted to that's how we
interact with games and when I look at
the overwatch League I'm just not being
fed that and I don't expect the CDL to
be any better in fact my only
relationship with Call of Duty in the
call of duty world league comes from 100
thieves documenting their Cod team my
biggest concern is content this is the
stuff that fuels eSports this is how we
get to know the players this is how
stars are born even on the broadcast
before the games are going on or after
the games are going on and in the almost
two years that I've been watching the
overwatch League I am just frankly not
convinced that Activision Blizzard can
make that stuff work good enough to
justify all this cost the biggest stars
in overwatch they're not being brought
to me I I don't know anything about
Sinatra but I know everything that
courage ate for breakfast and that made
shots obsessed with fast food that's the
point I'm trying to make here if you're
gonna charge me twenty five million
dollars to get into a league make these
players into superstars
isn't that why all of these faceless
people in suits are investing in your
video game League so that they can
capitalize off of the fans that
superstars bring in and without content
there's no superstars thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]